dozens of lives suspended in 20 floors
of concrete one of them is 47 year old
Michael who has advanced cancer and
because of lockdown can't get the home
care he needs
so his younger sister Clara has given up
her job as a nurse to look after him and
has been forced to claim universal
credit it's a letdown in the lockdown we
find that we having to do most of the
care for Michael yeah so it's been the
letdown just things like district nurses
can't come around and see a priest he
can't come around and I've had to give
up working actually as a nurse and very
difficult to you know get any kind of
income and so it's just all very
isolating and yeah yeah I'm do that
because you look after product yeah I
mean I felt bad for my colleagues
because they're fighting really hard you
know and I wish I could be with them but
it's a risk because he's
immunosuppressed kovat 19 doesn't
discriminate between people but lockdown
does Cathy haven't got much storage
Susan lives with her husband three
children two of them autistic in a
one-bedroom flat in these cramped
conditions the virus has spread to each
member of the family no space it's be
tough to deal with because normally we
all go out to the park and get some
fresh air but you know now I just cook
up inside and build a new space to store
food as well that's another challenge
the impact of isolation is also
difficult if you're 77 and live alone on
the 15th floor after two weeks of
relying on the kindness of others for
supplies
Janet Taylor has had to get out what
brought you out of the house today
why didn't you tell me I gotta got it
for ya until now Joe has been doing her
shopping and taking the dogs for walks
I'm doing her shopping somebody in the
shared accommodations doing their
shopping just if you can't help my lil
you won't have heard of Whitstable house
the block where they live but everyone
knows the block next door and the
tragedy here created a community spirit
in the way the virus has done nationwide
but it also sparked questions over
social divisions and the virus is
beginning to do the same it's not just
about space the disparity of lockdown is
also economic people doing the kind of
jobs where they can work from home
aren't doing their conference calls from
tower blocks like these the resolution
foundation believes that about a half of
high earners are able to be flexible
about the location of their work whereas
only 10% of low earners who work from
home and that means there are a lot less
able to protect their income and they
have fewer savings to fall back on like
many in this block Stephens job is on
hold his income reduced and with a young
son he's finding this new life difficult
without bouncing off the walls only four
you could do is take him finally she
used to go out now and again and I know
people don't agree with that but you
know I just I think you know everyone
handles it in their own way
the police to stay indoors are important
but it's worth remembering the
sacrifices and challenges behind each of
those doors
Jason Farrell's Sky News